Kong Skull Island is the second movie in
legendary and Warner Brothers Godzilla
and King Kong monster birth and it
features a cool scene right at the end
of all the credits with some exciting
teases for the gods on a sequel king of
the monsters yippee-ki-yay movie lovers
it's Jan here and in this video I want
to take a look at what we can look
forward to in Godzilla 2 based on the
post-credits scene in Kong Skull Island
and I'm also going to talk a bit about
Godzilla versus Kong if you haven't seen
Kong Skull Island yet there are spoilers
ahead for that film plus the Godzilla
movies and Kong movies to avoid those
click here for my spoiler free review as
a movie and venture back here after
you've had a chance to see it okay then
let's get stuck in after all the credits
of rolled with C Tom Hiddleston and brie
Larson stuck in an interrogation room by
themselves they seem to be talking to
some mysterious unseen figures behind a
two-way mirror and they agreed to
pretend that Skull Island never existed
and they never went there Corey Hawkins
and Jing Chan then walk in and welcome
Hiddleston and Larson to monarch an
organization that covertly studies
monsters like Godzilla the two monic
staffs then explained to Hiddleston and
Larson that Skull Island is just the
beginning and that there are more
monsters out there they warn them that
the world never belonged to humans
instead it belonged to the monsters and
the question is how long it will be
before the monsters take it back Hawkins
then reveals that Kong is not the only
king and shows a set of files at
Monica's on other monsters this is when
we get to see some cave paintings of
Godzilla and three iconic kaiju Rodin
Mothra and King Ghidorah the final
drawing shows Godzilla fighting the
three-headed monster Ghidorah and as the
screen fades to black we hear the iconic
Godzilla roar okay let's look in more
detail at this post-credit scene and
what it means for the Newmont's diverse
Rodin is a type of Pteranodon that first
appeared on the big screen and Toho
Studios 1956 movie Rodin and was
initially a foe of Godzilla's in the
1964 movie Ghidorah the three-headed
monster Mothra as the name suggests is a
most like creature that has often been
portrayed as a savior
she's one of movie studio Toho's most
popular kaiju and is surpassed only by
godzilla in the number of movies that
she's appeared in she went up against
Godzilla in the 1964 movie Mothra vs.
Godzilla and also in 1992 Godzilla vs.
Mothra so it's quite
we'll see her as an antagonist to
Godzilla at least to start with in
Godzilla 2 by the way the 2014 Godzilla
movie included a couple of Mothra Easter
eggs that already choose the iconic
kaiju
matras name appeared on some labels
stuck together on an old dilapidated
tank at John Ford's former home and
there was a very heavy butterfly and
loss theme going on in Ford's class the
day the nuclear plant went down the
paintings of a dragon-like creature in
the end credits are representations of
King Ghidorah Ghidorah was a powerful
enemy of Godzilla Mothra and Rodan when
he first appeared in the door as a
three-headed monster the idea forged
auras multiple heads was inspired by a
Japanese mythological eight headed
creature in the 1964 Toho movie the
monstrous dragon is an extraterrestrial
being that hatches from an egg which
initially appeared to be a meteor
Ghidorah attempts to take over the earth
until Matra stands up to him with
Godzilla and Rodan eventually deciding
to team up with her to defeat Ghidorah
and send him back to space other
appearances of Ghidorah and Toho's
movies have him under the control of
aliens or time travelers and there's one
incarnation of him in which he the
heroics guardian monster the protector
Japan by the way the 2014 Godzilla movie
included a little Easter Egg to Ghidorah
via a submerged dragon head where the
female Muto had laid her eggs in San
Francisco it will be interesting to see
how the Godzilla king of monsters movie
combines Godzilla Rodin and Mothra with
King Ghidorah and weathers will follow a
similar path to the 1964 film whether
against each other to begin with until
they decide to combine forces to fight
the bigger threat of King Ghidorah Kong
Skull Island also sets us up for the
hopefully epic movie Godzilla versus
Kong in Skull Island we meet an
adolescent Kong who's already an
impressive a hundred foot tall but at
this size he would be very hard-pressed
to go up against Godzilla
he was 350 foot tall however during
Skull Island
Jhansi Riley's character Marlow mentions
that Kong is still growing and as the
film is set in 1973 that means that Kong
still has over 40 years of growth ahead
of him before he meets Godzilla in 2020
by the way this won't be the first time
that congregate Villa have done battle
on the big screen that was in the 1962
Japanese movie King Kong vs. Godzilla
which featured Kong getting stronger by
absorbing electricity from various
sources and
year to end somewhat inconclusively with
the pair falling into the ocean during
fight after which we only see King Kong
we emerged there the film characters
speculated that Godzilla survived still
according to Toho Congress victorious
and given that both Godzilla and
Congress source of anti-heroes I
imagined that at some point they could
still put their differences aside at
least temporarily to try to potentially
even bigger foe so how hype do you now
for Godzilla 2 king of monsters and
Godzilla vs. Kong's do you think
Godzilla will team up with Mothra and
Rodan to battle King Ghidorah and huge
you think would win a fight between
Godzilla and Kong let me know your
thoughts in the comments below
if you enjoyed this hit that like button
and why not subscribe for more reviews
Easter egg videos and cool movie backs
you can also tap or click the screen
here to watch more videos you might like
thanks for watching and see you next
time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers